hi there one thing i wanted to add i
forgot to put in my video about uh
learning russian
the source of my russian learning for
the last
five years a wonderful
place for vivid discussion yeah they
have their perspective that's somewhat
dissident if you want
but they have people there
in lively interviews every day
representing a variety of perspectives
on things russian or history or
economics
ekomuskvi is now available in our
libraries in our russian library at link
i should say that echo must be is
probably the largest has the largest
listening audience of any radio station
in moscow
right now they're following the
elections the mayor elections in moscow
and all of the topical things that
happened in russia and around the world
it's a wonderful place to learn russian
and to learn about russia and to learn
about events around the world middle
east north america you name it how did
this come about
uh matpay ganopolsky who is one of the
voices of
echo musk v who's regularly on there
commenting on events was in vancouver
um i sent him an email i became aware
because i buy my russian dvds and books
at this
bookstore called the russian world here
in vancouver very nice bookstore if you
live in vancouver
and uh i became aware of the fact that
matvey ganapolsky was coming to
vancouver to give a talk
i spoke to the lady in the store that i
had tried to
communicate with ekhamus fee about
possibly using their material at link
and had been unsuccessful in getting any
kind of a reply but i'd be looking
forward to meeting mr ganapolsky and lo
and behold so i sent gunaposki an email
saying i would like to invite you to
dinner or lunch while you're in
vancouver i didn't get a reply
but
i got a phone call
from the bookstore saying mr ganopolski
is here he would like to speak to you so
i spoke to him on the phone
and he said look i've got a couple of
hours now i'm in downtown vancouver if
you want to come down we can have a chat
so i went down there and he's a
wonderful man very warm very you know
talking about things in russia which
with such enthusiasm
and we had a great conversation and i
asked him i said can we use your
material at link everything that's in
our library is available for free
download
uh
for advanced learners it's it's just the
best material that's out there because
everything has audio and text and so you
can save words and phrases it's been my
major learning material for the last
five years and i think it's great and so
forth and so on and he agreed
so i just wanted to announce that that
those of you who are i would say
intermediate and you can start using it
i started using it when i was quite
intermediate there are a lot of unknown
words and i just worked my way through
it because the contact content is so
interesting and so lively typically
these are interviews on topical subjects
uh both in russia and around the world
so i just wanted to add that
thank you